the information that has been given to  us in the Muller report clearly  constitutes adequate information to  begin an impeachment proceeding in the  House of Representatives no matter how  many times Mitch McConnell or the rest  of the Republicans want to wish that  away it's there in black and white in  the report this is not a fight I wanted  to take on but this is the fight in  front of us now this is not about  politics this is about the Constitution  of the United States of America we took  an oath not to try to protect Donald  Trump we took an oath to protect the  cotton serve the Constitution of the  United States of America and the way we  do that is we begin impeachment  proceedings now against this president